what is the most critical thing that a
director should do when reading and
reviewing a script okay good question
and this is one of the hardest things to
do and I can tell you as a director it's
really very difficult you get a script
you starting to read it and we're
assuming before you start reading it's
something that you're being asked to
consider to direct or along those lines
this may be something you're going to
work on or not let's assume that you are
the most difficult thing to do while
reading it is to not direct it now I can
tell you as a director I start reading
something and I see directorial problems
immediately or directorial opportunities
immediately like oh I know I could cast
in that role or I know where we could
shoot suddenly my mind is directing my
mind is figuring out how to get this
thing that I'm reading which I haven't
finished reading yet up onto the screen
and I haven't given the story a chance
to impact me I have taken a side street
the hardest thing to do is sit down can
I sit down with this story which happens
to be a script but it's a story in
script form and can I just read it and
emotionally respond to it just respond
like we all do when we go to see a movie
hopefully we sit down and just respond
it's going to be my first and only time
I get to do this without knowing the
story
so my response the first time through is
really crucial so what I suggest to a
lot of directors to do and this is in
one of my books directing feature films
thing I call the script wash can you sit
down with a script take a script nothing
written in it to accept the script
itself no none of your notes read it and
as you're reading it and as you're
responding it can you note what your
response is
not your directing I your reader I your
audience I when you're moved when you
feel sad when you feel confused when you
feel intrigued Wow
what's going to happen to him woo this
is an interesting idea wasn't expecting
that in other words can you note and I'm
seriously I mean it seriously write it
in right in there what you're thinking
and feeling as you're going through the
script as you're responding to the
characters as you're responding to the
events even it doesn't make sense I
don't understand why they're doing this
and maybe three pages they do I get it
that's a response that's an audience's
response to the story can you do that
you need to do that because basically in
the making of the film that's what
you're expecting the audience to do you
have to create something that they're
going to do that and this your emotional
journey to the film is sort of a guide
for where you want to do it actually
what you want and since you can only
make the film for one person you you
want to create something on the screen
that now does the same thing to you now
as that scripted the first time you read
it that's your goal it sounds like
you're meditating on the script you know
there's a term monkey mind in meditation
so it sounds almost like the monkey mind
is the directors voice yeah in your in
your ear and you've got to get rid of
that yes you have to end this it also
applies to actors producers anybody else
everybody starts shifting into their
role actors are reading oh I could do
that well I don't know how I would
suddenly as an actor you're not giving
the story a chance to impact you you're
not giving those characters a chance
you're getting you are getting in the
way so your your right is sort of
meditative shutting up the monkey mind
shutting down the director actor
producer writer voice in your head and
just allowing allow yourself like a
meditation allowing yourself to just
respond to what's coming to you can you
do that it's really really hard
I would imagine it would almost prove
someone to not be at home it sounds like
to read something in another setting
because they'd be too distracted is that
something you advise or to get out of
their own way but if you're at home and
then you see oh the cat's water needs
changing or differently you're not going
to be in the story possibly yeah I think
it's a great idea I think as an
individual you have to say where can I
under what circumstances can I
experience this script as purely as
possible okay
now I'll tell you one way this is really
so sound weird but it can work have
somebody read it to you and now you're
not reading now you're listening now
you're hearing a story told now that may
work better for you if I said to Elsa I
said I wish I can just read the scene to
me now I'm hearing it I I just want to
get it I want it to come at me in a
different way and so do you have a list
of let's say emotional words that you
want to jot down so that you're getting
out of the director aka monkey mind and
jotting down the emotional language so
that I'm sort of I don't know if they're
emotional words there's a shorthand that
I have when I read a script that I
understand I can tell you what one one
thing if I'm reading and something
doesn't make sense one word will do it I
write in really with a question mark
completely you're going to go that
that's what's going to know that so that
that's that's me tracking where my mind
so next time I'm reading through it and
I go I can see right there I had that
questions right there I had confusion or
disconnection or disassociation not I'm
not saying this is good or bad that's
just what I did what I did if someone
else may not or I may read it again and
go oh yeah I can see why I did that but
now I can see it's not a problem
whatever I may have a different
relationship to it another way to
do ever say I read a script and Elsa
hasn't read it and I may say let me tell
you the story now I'm going to tell it
I'm not going to read it to her I will
tell her this story in fact we did this
the other day I started to tell her this
now my telling of the story now I'm in a
storytelling mode and I'm trying to I'm
focusing on taking her on a journey
through it I'm not really directing it
and I'm getting her response so that
that's another relationship again back
to the story I'm not in the process of
directing at all I'm trying to stay as
close to the story to understand and I
think that the most difficult thing we
have is I have a script my job
eventually I can't do it on the first
reading my job eventually is to
understand where the writer was coming
from what the writer was intending to do
I really can't get that to that without
talking to the writer eventually but
prior to that with the script wash I
have to establish my relationship to the
story my fascination for my intern what
I'm intrigued with when I'm confused
about to get my relationship in place
and then go to the writer and then start
to understand where he or she was coming
from even why she wrote the story what
she was trying to say what she wanted to
say why this character why is this woman
the protagonist oh I see well that's
what yeah I know those I have to get
back to their source not just the script
again this gets back to assumption we
were talking about before I can follow
into the trap of it so assuming this is
what she was trying to do I can't tell
you the number of times I've read a
script and it's very clear I can make an
assumption I think I know what the
writer is trying to do here what the
writers trying this story I try and tell
and I meet and talk with the writer I
was so wrong
I was so now they did they tell the
story that they wanted to know not at
all
is the story they wanted to tell
interesting absolutely did I miss it
I totally missed it but let's go back to
the source that's the store
you want to tell okay there was a lot of
things in here that are off-track the
story they want to tell is way more
important than the story they have told
we try to bring those two together so
that's what that's the danger of
assumption if I start directing in my
mind before I've even had that
conversation I'm not done on a track
that eventually the writers go saying no
no that's not what I wanted and the
reason I've made a mistake is I didn't
check to see really where the writer was
coming from so you do the script wash
you you read it for a sort of emotional
effect you talk to the writer and then
at what point do you then turn on the
directors mind and say okay now I'm
reading the script with an intentional
directors mind turned on I would say
first of all um the dredges mind sort of
starts to seep in pretty early and as I
said before it's hard to keep it quiet
because that director mind wants to
direct it's a very eager little puppy in
there going we have a script we have a
story let's make it the dirt during that
the process of working with the writer
the directors mind is working it's
working a lot because I can hear from
the right of what he or she is trying to
do the story they're trying to tell and
my director mine is not thinking okay
how can i facilitate that or what's in
the way of that or how can we explain
that or does this mean we need another
scene now I'm sort of writing a little
bit but I'm not writing and or I can
hear what the writer wants I go okay
that's a great idea I have no idea how
to get that on the screen it's a great
idea but that just doesn't seem feasible
to do that so now I have to talk to the
writer and actually say that now the
director mine is working because the
director down here down the stream and
saying we've got a problem
trying to make this let's see if we can
solve that here with the writer so the
directors mind is working rather soon
once we get to a script that I feel is
very strong I'm confident about it
although it's not the final draft
as you probably know the final draft of
the script is when the picture is locked
at the end and because the script is
always shifting because it's an organic
entity but once we get to the point
where we think we can go into
productions and really consider what the
producers were going into production now
the directors mind is really working a
lot and now it has to start to take over
because now the directorial process is
moving pulling now I'm thinking about
thinking more about even though I've
thought about it before I'm thinking
about casting and I'm thinking about
locations and elements and the team that
I want to put together to help tell this
story but I have to make sure that I
have a script that is the strongest I
believe we can do by we I mean myself
the writer producers whoever else is
involved at that time there could be a
lot of people they're all they're all
involved that we've got the best we can
do knowing it's going to change and
believing that the change will only be
for the better whatever it is then then
I can start to take over there's the
director and start making demands and
and influencing it from the directors
point of view
you